[Musica]
questo qualcosa e anche una tecnologia
ma non intendo tecnologia con una
sezione
moderna un qualcosa che mi era il futuro
anzi esattamente il contrario parlo di
meglio parlare di qualcosa che guarda
completamente al passato che cos'è
questa cosa sono le lettere
infatti magari nessuno di voi sia
pensato ci pensa in generale ma 23 le
lettere ormai da diversi secoli a questa
parte ci sono molti professionisti
perché perché le lettera non subito e
tutti subiscono un e brewster che dura
da millenni sostanzialmente ma non tutto
è pronto ci pensano e queste figure
professionali che stanno dietro le
lettere quali sono
beh innanzitutto potremmo dire che ci
sono i calligrafi michele liberti sono
quelle persone che studiano e il
producono gli stili tradizionali quindi
due le tre le scrivono sostanzialmente
con degli strumenti e professionali
appunto che sono appennini di varia
natura pennelli e quant'altro per il
mese di un approccio alla scrittura
molto diverso da quello a cui siamo
abituati a tutti che magari a ge.am
scriviamo giusto con la biro supersic
mentre siamo al telefono
quel paese che invece è probabilmente si
avvicina di più a tutti noi
quotidianamente invece è la tipografia
dietro la tipografia ci stanno delle
figure professionali che si chiamano
type designer perché perché la
tipografia che cos'è è sostanzialmente
metto insieme una serie di caratteri in
un sistema far interagire tra di loro e
fare in modo che questi caratteri
possono scrivere ed essere eletti
tra l'altro scelta ai designer e brave
il libro della tipografia alcune
funzionale per un ambito molto ampio
immaginatevi di scrivere una mail alla
fonte o in cui la scrivete e
piccolissima o immaginatevi di vedere
quello stesso carattere stampate enorme
su un manifesto
se dai cos'è il design è stato bravo noi
quella fronte la leggete perfettamente
in entrambi i casi noi ci sono le
persone che come me si occupano di
lettering in mclean che cos'è è una via
di mezzo tra la calligrafia e la
tipografia per progettare con il
lettering delle molte rubiamo le regole
alla calligrafia delle volte alla
tipografia ma la sostanziale differenza
è che quello che si progetta con il
lettering a un utilizzo molto molto
specifico mio disegno ad esempio loro tv
e le lettere che ho disegnato per quello
di tipo non le posso prendere
toglierebbe contestualizzarle e crearci
qualche cos'altro perché non
funzionerebbero più
probabilmente a questo punto vi starete
chiedendo ma perché si parla di questo o
meglio che cosa c'entra con il
mediterraneo tutto questo beh in realtà
c'entra moltissimo con il mediterraneo
c'entra perché se noi prendiamo in
considerazione
l'alfabeto latino cioè quello che tutti
usiamo tutti i giorni e che anche quello
più diffuso nel mondo tra l'altro
scopriamo che è grazie al mediterraneo
che noi possiamo utilizzare che si è che
si è voluto infatti c'è stato un periodo
in cui il mar mediterraneo veniva
chiamato mare nostrum il periodo in cui
una grandissima civiltà un'antica
civiltà cioè quella dei romani ha
unificato sostanzialmente tre continenti
perché aveva unito europa parte
dell'asia parte del nord africa questi
beppe lì erano
tenuti insieme potremmo dire con un
termine due oggi stavano sotto un'unica
bandiera
nonostante le grandissime differenze
avevano obiettivi comuni di liberali a
seconda dei secoli anche una politica
più o meno centralizzata
e incredibile pensarlo ad oggi perché le
stesse popolazioni che gli stessi
territori hanno enormi differenze beh
come hanno fatto a essere uniti in quel
dato periodo storico belle hanno fatto
grazie anche ad una quella tecnologia di
cui vi sto parlando ovverosia le lettere
di più la cosa curiosa è che la
primissima traccia di di questa
tecnologia della sua evoluzione
lui e la troviamo esattamente dove siamo
oggi cioè ad ischia i primissimi reperti
di come questa tecnologia ha iniziato ad
evolversi ea diventare quella che oggi
conosciamo vengono proprio dal luogo in
cui siamo infatti se volessimo tracciare
una brevissima storia perché come ho
detto è la tipografia o comunque le
lettere in generale hanno un evoluzione
millenaria potremmo interiorizzarla
molto velocemente
potremmo dire che dapprima c'erano i
geroglifici bisogno glifi c erano
particolarmente complessi erano sapere
una tecnologia nelle mani di pochissimi
ad esempio gli scritti dei tempi sono
stati semplificati sono stati resi più
alla portata di tutti e sono diventati
appunto una tecnologia in mano a un
pubblico sempre più ampio a questo punto
i greci hanno preso e li hanno portati
nel territorio in cui ci troviamo oggi e
naturalmente i romani hanno preso
tantissimo dai greci e quindi ecco il il
filo conduttore diciamo
ma di tutto questo non serve essere dei
grandissimi esperti per per capire
questa cosa per vedere il collegamento
perché se io vi chiedessi qualcuno
conosce il times new roman se
probabilmente tutti voi l'avete
utilizzato tantissime volte immagino
bene questo carattere che è molto molto
famoso in realtà non ha un collegamento
direttissimo con con i caratteri romani
di cui vi voglio parlare ma se andiamo a
vedere bene la alla sua storia deriva da
un altro karate che si chiama gross
cicero che ha un carattere 1500 ecco che
cosa è successo è successo che nel 1500
gli umanisti di quel periodo hanno
iniziato a guardarsi intorno cosa
vedevano intorno a loro beh le lettere
dei romani ovverosia quelle lettere che
si trovano tutt'oggi come quella volta
incise in lapidi monumenti iscrizioni e
quant'altro puntino nero avevano queste
lettere tra l'altro molto eleganti molto
ben fatte queste lettere lo guardavano e
hummer a un certo punto iniziato a
ridisegnarle c'è stata una logan una
grande scopo una riscoperta del classico
e che cosa hanno fatto io me ne stiamo
cercato di disegnarle settembre le
introduzioni chiede quadrati cioè
razionalizzando perché era un po il loro
modo di vedere il mondo che avevano
intorno
e sono nate una certa tipologia di
carattere che prendevano direttamente
appunto da da quelli romani
quelli romani tra l'altro hanno una
caratteristica che hanno le grazie le
graffe sono quella quella particolare
forma arcuata all'inizio e alla fine di
tutte le aste perché ed è questa la cosa
che non ci portiamo dietro ancora oggi
una delle particolarità che vediamo
intorno a noi tutte le volte che usiamo
un certo tipo di lette nel 2000 fuori
quel particolare tipo di lettere proprio
perché al contrario degli umanisti e
invece l cercavano di razionalizzare
disegnare in un certo modo i romani le
prima dipingevano sui loro monumenti
quindi sera un calligrafo dell'epoca
diciamo che le dipingeva poi arrivava
uno scalpellino delle borgate mensili
eva è proprio il metodo di come venivano
costruite portava nei loro forma
estetica sostanzialmente
se noi volessimo fare un esempio ancora
più pertinente
molto molto che ci fa capire
perfettamente che cosa che cosa succede
nelle lettere che noi usiamo potremmo
vivere questo
questa è la colonna traiana la colonna
traiana si trova a roma a quasi un paio
di migliaia di anni diciamo e invece
questo è un font molto più moderno che
tra l'altro ha 33 anni perché è stato
disegnato nel 89 l'anno in cui sono nato
io non si chiama traian colonna traiana
traian se notate sono praticamente
uguali le differenze sono pochissime e
questo a me suscita scalpore cioè vedere
che una cosa che a duemila anni è stata
ripresa pari pari potremmo dire nel 89
tra l'altro per implementare le prime i
primi assetto tipografici per computer
e poi cosa che a me affascina tantissimo
in generale
io
come avrete capito un bambino le lettere
le lettere ci penso prati diana mente le
uso per per lavorare ma non solo per
lavorare
chiuso statica quindi quando sono ferme
le uso per disegnare dei loghi l'uso per
disegnare delle composizioni che delle
volte perdono addirittura in mero valore
di
di leggibilità e diventano delle
immagini con il lettering inizio prima
delle volte il bisogno notte per esempio
nel motion design penso molte le lettere
e penso anche delle volte a come doveva
essere la vita di un antico romano ad
esempio
magari doveva fare un viaggio questo
anti pero mano da una parte all'altra
del mondello era conosciuta ci volevano
mesi ci volevano anni lui partiva da
casa e interno vede da queste iscrizioni
questi segni questi simboli e gli
riconosceva naturalmente gli sembravano
familiari beh partiva attraversava
deserti attraversa la catena montuosa e
arrivava dall'altra parte del mondo e
che cosa trovava belli meno questi gli
stessi segni quelle stesse lettere
uguale identica probabilmente lui si
sentiva a casa nonostante la distanza
inimmaginabile per l'epoca e nonostante
noi oggi abbiamo tantissime tipologie di
carattere in un abbiamo solo più
imbarazzati lapidari come si chiamano in
gergo e queste lettere ma ne abbiamo
veramente di tutte le tipologie di tutte
le fattezze in realtà noi che cosa fanno
un giorno il mero potere che quello di
unire le persone di quelle gare popoli
di fare sostanzialmente
comunicazione e la comunicazione che
cos'è è la cosa più importante che
secondo me noi oggi possiamo fare
[Applauso]